like to welcome Florine from JetBrains
thank you for coming here my name is
Florian I work for jitteriness as a
developer advocate currently doing
mostly go lands or go ID but today I'm
here to speak about something else I'm
here to tell you how I build micro
services in an NGO in about 40 minutes
or so half an hour and like I'm just
going to jump right through the code
because this is going to be a live
coding session and it's also the first
time I do it so let's see how it goes
right so this is not micro service right
it's just the hello world basic
application that you get and see and as
you can see you can actually run it and
it will print hello world at some point
just note my laptop is one of those
ultra low voltage laptops that doesn't
understand CPU or anything so like go
compile takes a while but it works so
yeah skipping onto the actual code like
usually when you have the hello world
right like the first thing that you want
to do here is like oh I don't want to
too hard to-- this right so you'll
you'll see something like oh i just
convert this store constant and i call
this let's say the message that i want
to have right so now I have that okay so
this is still working compiling and Sun
so let's transform this into an actual
micro service something that uses Pyrus
I need HTTP which learnt recently so
first thing you would need a MUX in
something that actually takes your
requests and routes them accordingly
right so we can say oh I want a new Macs
right and now I want to actually use it
so it's gonna be something like that
like a variable right and then I want to
say something like I want a handle func
to actually handle the requests and for
this example we'll just use something
like I want to handle the requests to
the home page and I want to have let's
say the
classic interface - like the classic
function to handle this let's move this
to the internal and instead of like
writing the hello world will just write
the message as we normally do right and
[Music]
now this one needs still a bit of work
because we need to do HTTP listen and
serve right so we need to give it an
address and we need to give it an
address on 88 let's say on all addresses
on my machine and I need to give it the
marks and now like this is the basic
hello world when it comes to HTTP
servers if I run this it's going to work
there's nothing printed on on the screen
anymore but if I go here and if I do run
I can see if so I can see hello world
written by HTTP and I see the the
headers that the request generated right
so so far so good let's make this a bit
more useful and I'm one trick that I
picked up while writing though is that
it's always a bit faster for you to
provide certain information about your
response rather than not so this is sort
of like a micro optimization if you want
but it's a good one so let's say we do
the right header because we know it's
going to be a status okay right and we
also do something like we want to give
it a hint about the content type the
content type detection ingo takes quite
a while if you don't provide it
especially on like bigger responses
because it needs to detect like okay are
you writing a JSON stream or are you
writing a an HTML page or XML or
whatever so in this case sorry HTTP
there where I forgot my shortcut for
this one I've done play
where's my HTTP had a sorry this one
later content type so we can provide it
the content type and like I said this
one usually speeds up your request when
you'll see it if you benchmark it on my
machine where it took 36 milliseconds to
actually write hello world it's not
gonna be that obvious but we can try
so we compiled and we let's say we run
this again sorry my laptop is not meant
to do like that so it you can see some
some difference it's 25 milliseconds now
right right okay so next this is not
really a micro service and there are
some things that we are not doing here
so for example how many of you didn't
know that listen and serve returns an
error okay
so you should handle that error in case
you don't know about it mainly because
you can you can have cases where for
example your port is blocked by another
application and if you don't handle that
then your application will be like oh I
can't start and like just crash but you
won't know why like purification can be
perfect like 100 percent coverage 100
percent tests working it just has to
start right so let's say we don't want
to do that and let's load this as a
fatal error and I said something like I
know server failed to start right and we
can provide it in the error as well
right so now we handle errors because
that's what we don't in go okay so the
next step would be let's transform this
into like a more resilient web server
how many of you have have seen the blog
blog posts from CloudFlare about how to
serve pages on the internet especially
when you are using TLS ok one person
I expected more but it's good so I'm not
gonna write like I have to predefined
configurations for this one because I'm
like I just can't remember all of that
but it's gonna be in the final
repository and you can use it this is
the address where you can actually find
the blog post it's brought CloudFlare
and it's called exposing go on the
internet and if you go there you can see
all the options that I'm adopting here
and like it tells you how to set your
ciphers what's your minimum TLS
configuration and so on to actually make
it the secure web server and the next
step so once I've done that so now I
have my TLS configuration to be able to
serve HTTP HTTPS traffic I want to also
have a custom server because the
standard built-in need HTTP package does
have a already created server which is
the one that's behind listen and serve
but you don't necessarily want that all
the time and you don't want necessarily
that one because you let's say I want to
set a different time out for reads or
for rights and those timeouts are by
default quite large I think ten minutes
and I'm not sure if you want to have a
timeout on a request and in on an
inbound requests for ten minutes because
then someone can actually mess up with
your server quite badly so let's let's
move the service here right now we have
the server and we can change this to a
SRV and then SRV doesn't take any
parameters so we pardoned our server
already in few lines of go more
importantly like if I if I look at these
these a couple of lines of these few
lines of configuration you can also be
abstracted so I can put these in a
separate package that I can always use
so let's say like I move this into a new
server right so for now this
kind of works it's it's in some function
and Sun one thing that I would like to
do now is to add an environment variable
here and read it because it's going to
be easier for me to run it for example
from from go from a docker container and
we'll jump to the container later on and
let's just add some environment
variables right now and we'll jump into
them in a second so I've already
predefined these right and I have this
address now I would like to pass that
address always to my builder function so
that I can change it just from the
configuration and I don't have to like
carry where I do the change from and
server address and this one is a string
okay so now that I have a server address
here this one still needs something so I
said TLS and HTTPS right but we use
where's the configuration so we use the
semester which means still HTTP so let's
convert this one to a listen and serve
TLS and this one accepts the certificate
that you want use for the personal
purpose of the demonstration I'm
actually using some self-signed
certificates because yeah there's I'm on
localhost that it's fine
and I'm gonna read them from from the
disk rather than like fetch them from
somewhere else like a net CD storage or
something similar but yeah that that one
is a new depends on how you provision
your infrastructure and we can do
something like this so we need the third
file and we need a key file as well so
now that I have those two in place
hopefully if I've done everything
correctly this one still works and let's
change to let's do all requests on HTTP
this time around
okay and that's it I'm on HTTPS now you
can see I've made a request to HTTP
localhost I've used the Etsy host file
to actually map that host locally and it
works so in just a few lines of go code
like what less than 68 you can have a
secure web server already in go and it's
configurable to how you want it I also
said earlier that probably you want to
use this as a separate package so let's
just move this one to a different
package
unfortunately the resolution doesn't
seem to help me here okay fair enough
we'll do this manual way okay so let's
create a new package here called server
so you can reuse this pretty much
anytime and because we are in the server
package we can just call it new there's
no there's no need for that so now that
I I've done that change right everything
should be back to normal and like I can
reuse that package now safely if I want
I can test it but like right there's not
much to test there right it's just
configuration if you want to test
ofcourse its structure values correctly
and yeah that's fine if I'm not sure if
that's going to be helpful or not okay
and the other thing is we still have
this built in function here right
disclosure that we want to move so first
let's move this somewhere else outside
let's call it home handler right
and yeah this starts looking a bit more
like a go service and I'm gonna
apologize for this but I actually think
it's gonna be easier to exit the
presentation mode for a second because I
really want to move this one into a
different package so you know the idea
of packages is that you want to
structure your code on functional units
and you can see blog posts from Peter
Bergen from I know her by by the name
jbd or rocky hill if you if you know her
by the Twitter handle
there Bill Kennedy wrote a couple of
blog posts on how to structure and how
to think about your packages and the
idea is that you want your packages to
express units of work not necessarily
type of work so I don't necessarily want
to have a package called handlers I want
to have package called homepage I mean
it's a bit forced as an example but you
can think of a package named checkout
right where where you have all the
checkout logic and that doesn't mean
necessarily just the handler the HTTP
handler that takes care of the request
but you can also have their the database
interaction part or you can have the
template rendering part so that
everything is encapsulated in a single
package and it's easier to see and
that's that's what I want to do if this
one so let's let's move this onto a
package called I don't know homepage
right and I'll move it wait I need to
move the message as well because we
actually depend on the message constant
and I don't care about that anymore to
be in the main package so now I have
that package right and it's easier to
[Music]
group here everything that's related to
the homepage
however what I found useful when when I
was working with refinery services was
that it's better not to have functions
directly because you probably will as
handlers because you probably will have
dependencies on other packages so for
example you have a dependency on the on
a database or on the logging package and
you want to somehow inject those
functionalities in it I could go and say
something like oh I want to log here I
know let's say print line I'm starting
the server right so I can do that and
then I can do something in the home
handler which says oh I've received a
request right so now I use the log
package in two places but I don't have
necessarily control and what happens
with that logging library if I want to
now let's say log to standard error
instead of standard out or if I want to
use a different format for the logging I
need to be careful to either the package
to be well-written enough so that it can
process that request from me as a user
or I need to do the work twice right so
I was saying earlier I want to inject
that dependency on the logging package
and the built-in logging library has
something called a can actually create a
new logger so you can say log that new
right and you can choose worked right
for example and I want to write to SD
out I want the prefix let's say graphic
on UK and I want the standard flags
flags and I want the short filename
because you can actually get a file name
of of the line that prints that calls
the log function so you can make your
life easier debugging and generally I
found that in my code
or I can trace quick enough from where
the log line came from by the file name
so I can do short log short filing yes
so short file name right but again how
do i how do i send this to the to the
home handler let me check this here and
change this year and now if like
everything in main is fine and i have to
prefix i have the flags but i can't use
it in home handler so exchange this a
bit in home handler as well first and
foremost we can create a type structure
let's say and in this case we can say
something like I don't know handlers
it's not a very pretty name but that's
the best I can do right now and we know
we want to use a logger inside here
which is of type logger I want to move
this one so I can remove the handler now
because it's going to be redundant and I
want to move this on on a pipe so I'm
gonna have H handlers and to use a
pattern that's pretty frequent in go
like you will see functions being used
as constructors and in that case let's
say we want to write a constructor for
our handlers you can call it new
handlers and wine you and not make for
example is that if you look at the
standard library new is used whenever
you return a pointer and make his return
when you return the actual type not the
pointer to the type and that's a pattern
that you'll see for example if the new
and make functions and if you look at
other packages they use the same naming
convention for them so you can do this
and then I have the handlers here I said
I want to dependency on logger and I
want to do a return here
logger right so now I can build the
package oh and that's a good point so
now the package is more usable I need to
build it here as well so I can say
something like Oh give me a H which is a
home page you and I can send my logger
and that's how it the dependency
injection go and especially when the
request has so when the request has a
dependency on on a data that's trust
request boundaries right I can do as
many requests as I want to log sorry to
tell homepage but those requests will
always use the logger instance like the
internally the new instance created then
I will I don't need to insert that at
request time because it's going to slow
down the request right all right so I
want to have that instance always
present there and the final step that I
need to do here now is just say hey log
logger and print line and that's it like
that's that's the way to do dependency
injection
what else can we do here well we felt
about middlewares in the in the previous
talk right and we can write our own in
the middle where's quite efficiently in
ingo using the standard library as well
and you can do something like let's say
the logger middleware right so this one
accepts a handle func which we've seen
right and returns the handle funk
because that that that's how go works
for HTTP package and we can I don't want
to return a null I actually want to
return a function so now we can actually
do some somewhere here and what I'll do
is I'm gonna move this from here right
so my request is still there let's put
it actually as a method on handlers so
we have access to to our dependency
right and then we can call okay I want
you to call the next one for me and
let's make this actually a bit more
useful let's say we want to time the
request so start time should be by now
and change this on a bit in how many
milliseconds let's say I now sub and
start right so that's how it can quickly
instrument your request and - sorry okay
I can put it in the first sure so I can
do this if I want okay so yeah there's
plenty of ways to approach this line
another thing that that's going to be
interesting to notice now that I'm
working in in my package right and now I
need to jump back in the main package so
to do some extra work plus if I want to
write tests for this it's going to be a
bit trickier because my my roots are
initialized in a different in a
different package right I don't like
this package doesn't have control over
where it's called and I don't want that
like generally I found that for me it's
easier to to have control over the whole
package and what it does in the same
place so let's move this part as well
and to do so I usually use a pattern
like this let's say
set up roads and I send the marks there
and what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
create the method here right and I can I
can basically cheat a bit on this one
and now all my package logic is
self-contained I I want to change this
one from / - I know homepage right I can
do that and by don't need to jump back
in main to change it but I want to do
logging for this that's what we started
doing so I can do this and that's it
that's how you do middleware management
for your app you can use G for example
which simplifies this or like gorilla
marks for example which has the built in
middleware logic but if you don't need
something more complex if you need
something like a lambda function running
on Amazon or on DCP or asure then yeah
like this this would be a minimal
example of running a lambda function
without having to have external
dependencies let's see if it actually
still works right we've done a bunch of
refactorings here and like everything
should still work but let's see so we
have actually let me see if I jump back
in presentation mode now so where's my
console so now we have the server
running we see the the date prefix as
well we see that this one actually was
written on mango line 27 so that's
correct so it's easy for me now looking
at log file to see what's going on there
right and if we do a request so the
request still works and we've seen that
well it's processed in zero seconds
things yeah I guess I can add a time out
there but like that's that's how we do
it right and what I don't have the time
but probably in like 20 minutes we've
we've written
laid solution for how to to serve HTTP
pages right the other thing is that we
probably want to write some tests I said
production right so unless you do test
what was the the saying yesterday the
TDD one test during deployment yeah so
unless you do test during deployment
yeah you probably want some tests right
so let's say we use the classic home
test function and we can how many of you
have have you heard of the table tests
okay a few
so basically when when you do a table
test right your tests look like this and
you basically have a struct a slice of
abstract where you define the name of
the test and then you define your inputs
and outputs and then you actually
arrange for the test and what I've done
here and you'll see there's a warning
that oh no this is shadowed this
actually is an intentional shadow
because if I want to run in parallel the
tests this will fail we've got that line
it's gonna mess up the order if anyone
saw the presentation yesterday in the
same room from Sean Kelly about the
message queues he basically explained
the problem there I do to the pointers
and how they work when you run the go
test - parallel it's gonna mess up your
test so I'm not gonna write the whole
test right now because it's too lazy but
I have the the best FREE define here
you can understand why I'm not going to
subject it to all of this the only thing
that I need to do is probably change
this a bit because I've changed the
names right so I have new handlers here
and I don't want to provide the logger
and I have a instant of handler let's
call it home right so this one actually
tests the actual handler doesn't test
the the workflow that your request to do
and that's something for you to explore
if you want on how to like you have all
the logic here to set up the routes in
order to be able to inject a test server
in it which basically will follow the
same approach we all let's go for this
one and explain so we want to have an
HTTP request as an input to our Handler
and we want to have an HTTP response as
an output that's how it works and we
have some expected pipes right we expect
a certain status and a certain body and
[Music]
there is a package called HTTP test it's
in standard library it's under net HTTP
HTTP test so this one is the import and
it has some cool features in there if
you don't if if you don't know about it
or haven't looked at at it yet have a
look because it it allows you to do some
interesting testing using the test the
HTTP interfaces and you can create a new
HTTP test request so you can actually
have a request created there with all
the correct fields and so on and in in
this case it's going to be a simple one
right it's going to be get me the home
page and there's nobody so this one is a
get request not post and I want to have
the response recorded told to me but
without using the actual HTTP response
that you normally get because that's
that's an interface and we want to know
more about our response not not just
what the interface
us to do if we go here the interface
that that we have in HTTP would give us
the right header right and header which
are not useful because we want to
actually see what happened in the
requests right so this is where HTTP
test new recorder comes in and gives us
the HTTP response recorder and we use
that here like we run our handler so we
actually call this with the input and
output parameters that we expect and
then we say okay tell me if the response
code was different from what I expect
and tell me if the body of the string is
different or not right so if I run this
it's gonna fail or not is it no it's not
so yeah I I reference the message
directly so that that's why it doesn't
fail but in your proper test like you
should probably write here your actual
test case right so if I would run it
again it will fail way right so now we
know it failed and we know why it failed
as well which makes it easier for you to
debug it as well so that's that's kind
of it like writing tests for for this is
a lot easier than bending clothes and
you don't need to try test as I said for
example for initializing the HTTP server
but there's no point in that what else
can we do we can do a docker deployment
so if demo works I already have to demo
the docker container right and this one
is using the like the latest features
available in the curve or one point no
sorry yeah 18.3 or something like that
when they introduced the multistage
building process where it allows you to
have a single docker file
you can do both the build step and the
actual container step at the end and
what I'm using is the go 111 beta
container just because why not test
testing go right I'm actually also using
case you haven't noticed it go mode here
I'll come back to that in a second
and like yeah that's that's how you
usually do like you add your
dependencies I prefer to vendor my
dependencies and actually commit them
with the code it's not necessarily going
to be needed since go 111 but I
generally advise for that because it
makes it easier to do the build step and
it makes it easy to track what changes
also you don't need to depend on github
or internet to do your build so like I
just need to add a directory this step
is actually needed in order to like run
without running as a root user inside
the container by default your container
runs as like the application inside your
container runs as root and maybe you
don't want that it's probably not a good
idea and I want to disable the Segoe
part because if I use the net package
it's going to automatically try to use
the system resolver which is rely which
means interacting with a sea library but
I want to like have a pure go build like
I don't want to depend on any Lipsy from
the system so then I can just say okay
disable the seco part and then run just
go build as I I do it before and in in
the actual container so where it says
final stage it's it's a classic
container like you you build it based on
Alpine and my copy whatever you need in
this case I need the SSL certs and the
build binary that we we've got from the
previous build expose the port and
that's it so let's see if it actually
works
oops wrong button right
so they actually delete that no we won't
see I actually deleted the the
configuration by mistake earlier sorry
okay I can skip on this one but you have
to trust me on it it it depends on
because my binary now depends on some
environment variables it will scream at
me if I run the build process so it's
not that exciting to run it what's
interesting is that I was also using in
case you haven't noticed this is the
path to my project so I'm using the new
go 111 go module feature or Vigo if
you've heard of it so I have actually
packages I'm not referring to them in a
relative path like my paths are like
normal packages I should probably format
this right so that's what go 11 brings
to us you can start doing this and stop
depending on go path and build your app
anywhere and yeah that's that's kind of
it I guess I'm sorry for the docker demo
but as you can see it kind of failed to
start because it doesn't have
permissions and so like I need to spend
a couple mins to configure it database
work there's a last step like inserting
the database would be as simple as
inserting the logger now because you
would say something like let's say
sequel X connects right so you would
have your sequel connection that you get
from the driver and then you just need
to say oh I need to do the database part
right so I add it as a parameter to my
function I add it all the way so sequel
X DB I prefer sequel X because it adds a
few more convenience features to that
and then I I want to have a DB which
abb right so I actually sequel DB right
so that's how you do sequel work
afterwards or anything else that you
depend on I like if this one would
actually give me a second where do I
have the import sequel X so now it's
going going to the internet the question
is it's going to is it gonna work or not
it worked okay
surprisingly the internet works in a
demo yeah and like now you could
literally start writing your your query
straight into it and you have like in
order to mock the database you'd mark it
only once and then provide it to all
your handlers for example and because
you inject it like that you don't have
to worry oh am i passing it to the
request or not and so on it's going to
always be on the handler struct and I
also advise you to use the functions
that have context at the end because you
can do this so you can provide them with
the context from your request let me
make this a bit less red so if you if
you use this type of work like
everywhere you need to connect to
somewhere or like execute the query use
the context from from your request as my
previous colleague spoke about like
you'll be able to cancel your request if
the client cancels those so you don't
need to do extra work right and that's
pretty powerful and I I've seen very few
packages that actually is this but if if
you're interested in saving some money
eventually or making your application
more performant knowing when the client
cancels or times out or anything happens
on the internet until it reaches your
server and like the connection
terminates that's a very useful thing to
do not to mention your tracing and so on
I think that's it
I think we are running out of time if
I'm correct yeah okay so if you have any
questions please let me know by if you
want to talk afterwards I can show you
some some more things yeah just feel
free to grab me around here yeah so five
minutes of questions or you can get an
early start to lunch okay you're using
your colon yes and using a lot of some
packs or something like that cuz it's
very neat so what kind of configuration
you are using I'm using the default
configuration so it's basically a lot of
generation of code yeah so it comes by
default with like I can show you after a
bit more if you want but like it comes
by default with a lot of built-in
configuration and so on and earlier when
I said that I kind of want to move it to
a different package and it didn't fit on
screen it's because Windows was scaled
already but like you can do a lot of
refactorings out of the box with it so
for example if I want these two to be in
their own function I can say oh I I just
want this to be a function right yeah so
that's a plug-in and there's another
plug-in for it to actually teach you
shortcuts I'm not sure how should I do
it let me see no no no I I know how to
do hints what what I wanted to show you
was the other thing like if I go here
like if I don't use shortcuts there's
going to be a different plug-in here
which tells me oh you're not using
shortcuts so I it also there's a
different plugin which allows you to get
help for for the shortcuts and like
teach you and so on and you have
statistics for them what yeah the other
present the other plug-in is called
presentation plugin and allows you to
have the shortcuts pop on on the screen
Heide
it's always the case in like homepage
packet but imagine a scenario that you
have users package which you're you have
an endpoint for your users you have the
user model defined there and you have an
author's package which has an API
endpoint for orders and in order model
us you're actually referencing to user
model right and you can also refer to
the order model from the user and in
this case you will find yourself in a
circular dependency hell I've been
wondering like in this kind of
structuring was like workaround for that
I mean for services it's kinda in a way
that might be abstracted by using some
sort of like interfaces like local
interfaces that abstract it and you will
inject it but especially like when you
are doing the modeling best tricky to
get right and you can easily find
yourself in this circular dependency
chain so yeah I actually bumped into
that quite frequently because it's like
that desire of like using let's say as
you said are the users from the order
and water from the users but if you
think about it you can also have a
different package which actually
combines the two of them into giving you
for example order history right or
something that's related to those two
units of work without having to have a
circular dependency so if if in this
case you want to see I don't know let's
say order history right you'd create a
package or order of histories and like
combine the functionality there so pull
the data from from your two other
packages in in that package it sounds a
bit more work but on the long run you
can still use the user packages is you
can still use the order packages
and then you can combine them to do
pretty much whatever you want with them
right and the logic will always be clear
because it's going to be contained in
that package so you won't have to think
about oh where did I place the function
that tells me how to retrieve the order
list for a user or the other way like
where did I place a function that tells
me to retrieve the users that place an
order for this item it's going to be
clear because it's in order history I
think it goes be like mind shifting if
you are coming from like classical regul
see MSE background because in there
you're just relying on activerecord to
give you like user dodi's yeah thank you
okay anyone else any questions
[Applause]